good news iOS 11 is here bad news
finding the best new tricks for your
iPhone basically requires one of these
number-one customized control center you
can now pick and choose the controls
that show up here by heading to settings
control center customize controls number
to edit screenshots you can still snap a
screenshot like this but now attack the
small preview in the bottom corner to
doodle crop add text arrows even a chat
bubble or consider number three
recording your screen yes video record
add the screen recording to your control
center then tap this button when you
want a record number for free up storage
low on space blame iMessage attachments
go to settings general storage review
large attachments and swipe to the left
to delete specific files number 5 move
multiple apps pull down on one app until
it shakes start moving it then tap more
apps to create a stack then take that
stack and drag it to wherever you want
including a folder number 6 type to Siri
Siri where can i buy feminine products
yeah sometimes you just want to type to
Siri go to Settings General
accessibility Siri type to Siri hold
down on the home button and type number
7 take better live photos if you have an
iPhone 6s or later take a live photo
then open the photo and swipe up from
the bottom to select a new effect like a
loop a bounce for long exposure number 8
read QR codes open your camera and aim
at the QR code it will launch Safari or
a link to the App Store no third-party
app needed number 9 scan documents open
up notes start a new note
tap the plus button then scan documents
take a photo and drag to the corners to
adjust then save and sign number 10 mute
I messages quickly swipe to the left on
a message and select hide alerts to shut
up that annoying messaging chain number
11 type one-handed tap the emoji icon on
the keyboard then select the left or
right-handed keyboard icon and type away
[Music]